the is that kid doing we tried to
make this as real as possible as sick as
that is see we're in a bow tie Score
says he said what do you want to do with
the Goldfish about it like a couple days
before maybe you clean the Fishbowl I
was all for it you know and he asked me
and I said well you know the guy really
ate a goldfish so I'll eat the Goldfish
this is what happens when you with
your pets on new issue day
they were like okay and then the next
day they were like well you know PETA uh
is not gonna let you eat a goldfish we
tried and they're not gonna really do it
and I was like well let's figure we
don't we have to figure something out so
I get there to shoot the scene and
there's three adult animal Wranglers
this this goldfish has three people in
its entourage on set that is three more
than I have with me on set and I was
allowed to have it in my mouth for three
seconds at a time no joke you can ask Mr
Scorsese or Leo to back me up I put the
goldfish in my mouth the first take and
it relieves itself in my mouth